it's such a compelling notion to me
that we're now working on all these
exciting machine learning systems
that are able to learn you know
from data and then if we can
have this other brain that's a learning
system
that's live wired in when on the human
side and
them to be able to communicate it's like
a
self-play mechanism was able to beat the
game the world champion
go so they can play with each other the
computer and the brain
like when you sleep i mean there's a lot
of futuristic kind of things that
it's just um exciting possibilities but
i hear you we understand so little about
the actual intricacies of the
communication of the brain
that it's hard to find the common
language
well interestingly
the technologies that have been built
actually require the perfect common
language so for example
hundreds of thousands of people are
walking around artificial ears and
artificial eyes
meaning cochlear implants or retinal
implants
so this is you know you take uh
essentially digital microphone you slip
and electrode strip into the inner ear
and people can learn how to hear that
way or you take an electrode grid and
you plug it into the retina at the back
of the eye
and people can learn how to see that way
the interesting part is
those devices don't speak exactly the
natural biological language they speak
the dialect of silicon valley
and and it turns out that
as recently as about 25 years ago a lot
of people thought this was never going
to work
they thought it was it wasn't gonna work
for that reason but the brain
figures it out it's really good at
saying okay look there's some
correlation between what i can touch and
feel and hear
and so on and the data that's coming in
or between you know
i clap my hands and i and i have signals
coming in there and it figures out
how to speak any language oh that's
fascinating so like
no matter your no matter if it's neural
link
so directly communicating with the brain
or it's a smartphone or google glass
or the brain figures out the efficient
way of communication well exactly
exactly
and what i propose is the potato head
theory of evolution which is which is
um that all you know our eyes and nose
and mouth and ears and fingertips all
this stuff is just plug and play
and the brain can figure out what to do
with the data that comes in and part of
the reason that i
think this is right and i care so deeply
about this is when you look across the
animal kingdom you find all kinds of
weird peripheral devices plugged in
and the brain figures out what to do
with the data and i don't believe that
mother nature has to reinvent
the um principles of brain operation
each time
to say oh now i'm going to have heat
pits to detect infrared now i'm going to
have
something to detect uh you know
electroreceptors on the body now i'm
gonna detect something to pick up the
magnetic field of the earth
with cryptochromes in the eye and so
instead the brain says oh i got it
there's data coming in
is that useful can you do something with
it oh great i'm gonna mold myself around
the data that's coming in
it's kind of fascinating to think that
we think of smartphones and all this new
technology is novel
as totally novel as outside of
what evolution ever intended or like
what nature ever intended
it's fascinating to think that like the
entirety of the process of evolution is
perfectly fine and ready
for the smartphone and the internet like
it's ready
it's ready to be valuable to that and
whatever comes
to cyborgs to virtual reality we kind of
think like
this is you know there's all these like
books written about natural what's
natural
and we're like destroying our natural
cells by like
embracing all this technology it's kind
of it's you know we're not probably not
giving the brain enough credit
like this this this thing this thing is
just fine with new tech
oh exactly it wraps itself around by the
way wait till you have kids you'll see
the
ease with which they pick up on stuff
and
yeah as kevin kelly said um technology
is what gets invented after you're born
but the stuff that already exists when
you're born that's not even tech that's
just background furniture like the fact
that the ipad exists for my son and
daughter like that's just background
furniture
so um yeah it's um because we have this
incredibly
malleable system it just absorbs
whatever is going on in the world and
learns what to do with it
so do you think just to linger for for a
little bit more
do you think it's
possible to co adjust
like we're kind of uh you know for the
machine
to adjust to the brain for the brain to
adjust the machine i guess that's what's
already
happening sure that is what's happening
so for example when when you put
electrodes in the motor cortex to
control a robotic arm for somebody who's
paralyzed
the engineers do a lot of work to figure
out okay what can we do with the
algorithm here so that we can detect
what's going on from these cells
and figure out how to best program the
robotic arm to move given the data that
we're measuring from these cells
but also the brain is learning too so
you know the paralyzed woman says
wait i'm trying to grab this thing and
by the way it's all about relevance so
if there's a piece of food there and
she's hungry
she'll figure out how to get this food
into her mouth with the robotic arm
because that
is what matters
you